I love whoever my children love and to
me their family and I embrace everybody
they bring home and you know Zane is
very special to me and you know he's
family
Yolanda Hadid is stepping out for Us
Weekly's a most stylish New Yorkers
party which was hosted by her daughter
Gigi's boyfriend
Zayn Malik it's a beautiful time in our
life the pay are hung out together
inside in the VIP lounge he's just a
really good person you know he comes
from very humble beginnings so he's just
a normal guy and he's a good human being
Yolanda was actually one of the Nights
honorees she recently relocated to NYC
from LA I love it I guess I took to New
York like a fish in the water and I'm
just so excited to be here and get
dressed again and just you know be alive
I think I have to step it up a little
bit and California is much more casual
you know I mean you can be in your
workout clothes every day and here it's
kind of it's fun to dress up you know
and I love the change of seasons and you
know really use that to make that part
of your wardrobe nice weather and
[Music]